the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and a
song of ice and fire video
in this video i would like to talk about
our old friend sir gregor clegane who is
also known as
the mountain that rides i'm sure all of
you remember
sandor clegane's enormously large
brother gregor clegane from the show
everyone knows how evil he was in the
show but believe it or not
his actions are far more disturbing in
the books
he is easily one of the most vicious
characters
in a song of ice and fire although most
of this information is very dark
i find it to be interesting nonetheless
because it does give us more insight
into who the mountain actually is
one of the very first things we learned
about sir gregor is what he had done to
his little brother
sandor clegane and only sansa stark's
second chapter in a game of thrones
the hound says i was younger than you
six maybe seven a woodcarver set up shop
in the village
under my father's keep to buy favor he
sent us gifts
the old man made marvelous toys i don't
remember what i got
but it was gregor's gift i wanted he had
a wooden knight
all painted up with every joint peg
separate and it was fixed with strings
so you could make him fight
gregor is 5 years older than me so the
toy was nothing to him
he was already a squire almost six foot
tall
and muscled like an ox so i grabbed his
knight
but there was no joy in it i tell you i
was scared all the while
and sure enough he found me there was a
brazier in the room gregor never said a
word
he just lifted me up under his arm and
he shoved the side of my face
down into the burning fire and held me
there while i screamed and screamed
you saw how strong he is even then it
took three
grown men to drag him off me my father
told everyone my betting had caught on
fire
and our maester gave me ointments
ointments
grigor got his ointments too four years
later
they anointed him with the seven oils
and he recited his nightly vows
and rhaegar targaryen tapped him on the
shoulder and said
arise sir gregor now although it wasn't
that much different from the show
i like that we got to hear the hounds
version of this event
what i find very interesting about this
story is what it said at the end
about four years after gregor burned his
brother's face
he became a knight of the seven kingdoms
anointed by none other than rhaegar
targaryen
jon snow's father you would have never
known this from only watching the show
this is ironic in a very sad and
unfortunate kind of way
because rehgar knighted the man who
would go on to commit
some of the most horrific acts against
his wife elia
and their children i'm sure all of you
remember what was said about this in the
show
when ober and martel arrived in king's
landing
i'm asking your question i've heard
rumors
so am i but what i keep hearing is that
gregor cleganed the mountain
raped elia and split her in half with
his great sword
i wasn't there oberyn scenes are some of
my favorite moments from that season
but let me show you how it was described
in the book
now i will say this was mentioned more
than once in the books but i want to
look at what it says in ned stark's
chapter
when he thinks about gregor clegane
because i think this is
when we get some chilling insight into
the character
this is what it said in ned stark's
chapter sir gregor clegane was the
biggest man eddard stark had ever seen
robert baratheon and his brothers were
all big men as was the hound
and even back at winterfell there was a
simple-minded stable boy named hodor
who was bigger than all of them but the
night they called the mountain that
rides would have towered over
even hodor he was well over seven feet
tall
much closer to eight with massive
shoulders and arms
thick as the trunks of small trees
unlike his brother the hound
sir gregor clegane did not live in
king's landing
he was a solitary man who seldom left
his own lands
except for when there were battles or
tournaments he had been with lord tywin
lannister when king's landing fell
a new maid knight who was only 17 years
old
even then distinguished by his size and
his ferocity
some said that it had been gregor who
dashed in the skull of the
infant aegon targaryen against the wall
and whispered that afterward he had
raped the mother elia martel of dorne
before putting her to the sword these
things were not said in gregor's hearing
and i don't blame them whatsoever ned
stark could not remember ever speaking
to the man
though gregor had ridden with them
during balon greyjoy's rebellion
but he was only one more night among a
thousand others who fought that day
ned stark was looking at sir gregor with
a bit of distress
let's face it the mountain made most
characters nervous
now this is where things get really
sinister
it said eddard stark seldom listened to
gossip
but the things cetus or grigor were more
than ominous
he was about to be married for a third
time and one heard dark whisperings
about the deaths of his first two wives
now just wait it gets even scarier
it was said that his keep was a grim
place where servants disappeared
unaccountably and even the dogs were
afraid to enter the hall
alright now actually think about that
for a second
this man not only killed several of his
wives but
even the servants would disappear
unaccountably
i mean this man is basically the
westeros version of a serial killer
it says that even the dogs were afraid
of him and that's insane when you
consider
that dogs are actually the sigil of his
house now imagine if the direwolves were
afraid of the starks
or if the dragons were afraid of the
targaryens
that just doesn't seem right because we
all know they have this amazing
connection to those animals
but sir gregor clegane is something else
if anyone or anything
is an animal it's him in the most
disturbing sense of the word
this wasn't everything ned stark has
heard though it gets even worse
ned also thinks about how the cleganes
had a younger sister who died under very
suspicious circumstances
he also thinks about the hunting
accident that had killed their father
this is how the mountain was able to
inherit the keep
the gold and the family's estate the day
this happens is also the same exact day
sandor clegane leaves home forever
to take service with the lannisters as
their sworn sword
i don't blame him either thanks to his
brother his entire family
is gone their childhood home has now
basically become a haunted house
anyone who goes there ends up missing or
dying
under suspicious circumstances none of
this was mentioned in the show
but now you can see why the hound hates
his brother so much
it's not only because he shoved his face
in the fire but it's also largely
because of what he had done to their
younger sister
i believe this is why sandor clegane
ended up growing so close to arya and
even sansa
he did not want what happened to his
sister to happen to them
now i wish they would have brought this
up in the show because it would have
helped fans understand why it had to be
the hound who fought the mountain
in the end this is why he would say his
hatred for
his brother kept him alive i reckoned
you were gonna die by the time i loaded
you on the wagon but you didn't
now i reckon you died a dozen more times
over the next few days but you didn't
what kept you going
eight if you haven't read the books then
you might not know this either
but many fans believe sir gregor no
longer has a head
under his helmet after the mountain
fights oberyn he slowly begins to die
because of the poison that oberyn had
on the tip of his spear cersei informs
qyburn that as soon as sir gregor dies
he is to then bring her the skull so she
can send it to dorne
since gregor clegane killed elia martell
in her children
tywin lannister swore that he would send
them his head
so that's what cersei has done the
alleged skull of sir gregor is brought
to sunspear
in that is thought to be one of the
largest skulls ever known to man
but it still could be a fake no one
actually saw qyburn remove the
mountain's head
but that also doesn't mean it's not gone
most would assume that the mountain is
now dead
now after cersei's walk of shame qyburn
introduces the newest member of the
kingsguard
he doesn't refer to him as the mountain
anymore either he now goes by the name
of sir robert the strong
the other members of the kingsguard
notice that whoever is inside the
massive armor
no longer eats any food drinks any water
or wine
nor does he go to the bathroom they also
can't see inside of the helmet
in the very last chapter of the last
book things begin to get
even more ominous about the character
mace tyrell says
where did this man come from why have we
never heard this name before
he does not speak he will not show his
face
and he has never seen without his armor
do we even know for
certainty that he is even a knight we do
not even know if the man is alive
[Music]
[Music]
you